aaron rodgers is the subject of plenty
of stories yesterday chris as to whether
or not he'll play this weekend
originally it became
it was perceived as as maybe an effort
by joe philbin the interim head coach to
be coy about whether or not they would
shut rogers down because these last two
games don't matter but then i saw the
injury report and rogers has had a knee
injury since week one but now he's on
there with a groin injury and and i
think that that may be the thing that
potentially could factor into the
packers thinking rogers has said he's
going to play rogers has said that he
feels compelled to play even though the
games have no meaning yeah but you know
here's my concern if i'm the packers
i've got so much money tied up in this
guy so much salary cap space devoted to
him why do i want to take any chance of
a serious injury that would affect his
availability for 2019 because i'm
already financially fully and completely
invested in this guy we don't have any
other options before the packers other
than deshawn kaiser we can't go out and
sign somebody else if he would suffer
some serious freak injury during one of
these meaningless games that's where i
think someone needs to talk to aaron
rodgers and say look because we're
paying you so much we have to put you in
bubble wrap for next year yeah it's it's
a tough spot i mean i certainly
understand that argument i do uh but you
know at the same time it's just another
case of hey football players want to
play football and you know this is what
he's there to do i think you know when
you're in a locker room and around 53
guys you you don't even you wouldn't i
wouldn't i'd never been in this position
but i don't think you would even feel
right going like oh they're just holding
me out these last two weeks and i'm okay
i could play but you know they don't
want to risk me but you know screw you
other guys and that's just not the way
football players think he wants to be
out there with the guys it's not been a
great year and he's gonna try to end it
off on a a positive note but yes
certainly risky within that but i just
think rogers likes playing the game too
much and he's gonna be out there
yeah but really when you look at that
financial investment and you look at
what the potential consequence would be
if something would happen to him you
understand why the packers may want to
say hey aaron just sit these two out
they really don't matter some pft props
coming at you right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports